Speaker 1: I told you earlier in the show
that America Fest held an event over the
weekend and it was horrible and dystopian.
And we are going to look at a few clips and
really it reminds me. These people are
dangerous, but they also. Are way better
than the left at organizing these sort of
pump up events. I'm going to start with a
clip of donald trump jr coming out and i know
that it's going to be, you know, it's funny,
it's cartoonish. It's like a wrestling intro.
It's also a little loud just as a heads up if
you're listening in headphones. But I'm turning
it down for us. But make fun of this at your own
peril because this type of stuff works. Here
is Donald J. Trump Jr coming out. But there's
also pyrotechnics if you're only listening.
Annie Hall. Yeah, I mean, listen, I'm with you
that it is hard not to laugh because it's so
absurd. But I've spoken so many times before.
The right knows how to throw these events,
coalesce people. They do multiple packs, turning
point USA does events. They've got America Fest is
one of them. They've got the Turning Point Summit,
all these different things. This stuff actually
does get people engaged. And part of the reason
that the youngest voting group 18 to whatever
isn't even more left skewed is that the right does
a way better job of activating and getting people
together and the pyrotechnics and the music and
the entire thing. The left doesn't have it. The
closest thing we had at one point was Netroots
Nation, which I used to go to but no longer do.
It's very milquetoast, it's very mediocre, a
lot of infighting, a lot of like, you know,
all the people that actually have success that
should be leading sessions. We have political
disagreements with them, so we're going to have
like it. It's a mess. It's a mess. The right
is actually better at this. So eventually Don Jr
spoke and again, he continues to be obsessed like
many of these people, obsessed with gender today.
Speaker 4: Pushing for three year old children to
be indoctrinated by their purple haired teachers
to go through aging, permanent sexual reassignment
surgeries. And if parents.
Speaker 1: And by the way,
the little skips these are in the source videos,
I unfortunately can't do anything about them.
Speaker 4: Parents want to get involved.
They're domestic terrorists. Oh, if
parents want to maybe be a part of that
conversation, let's be clear. That kid
can't buy a pack of Cigarets for another 15
years. They can't vote, although I want them to,
because of course, they don't know what they're
talking about for another 15 years. But they can.
Speaker 1: And we don't know
what Junior is talking about.
And I may not know for another 15 years.
Speaker 4: Decide to mutilate their bodies
permanently to satisfy some insane woke teacher.
Speaker 1: Satisfy. What is the deal with that?
Okay. Obsessed. Obsessed with gender. Obsessed
with imaginary things that aren't actually
happening and the gender obsession continued.
Republican Senator Josh Hawley. A sort of
pseudo insurrectionist though, is the way I
would refer to him. He came out and he said,
Here's an idea, boys, turn off the
porn and go talk to a real woman.
Speaker 2: Can.
Speaker 4: Give
yourself to and pour yourself out to young men.
Speaker 1: Pour yourself out into a woman.
Speaker 4: Let me make a suggestion to you.
Why don't you turn off the computer and
log off the porn and go ask a real woman.
Speaker 1: On a date? Right. How about it?
Unidentified: Thought I'd ask her out. Young man,
why don't you be the one to do the Asking.
Speaker 1: America Fest quickly turning into,
like, a pickup artist type conference instead of a
right wing political conference. I guess with this
pseudo incel group it's the same thing. But yeah.
Unidentified: Don't wait for her. You go ask, show
her a little respect, and then you take her out.
Speaker 4: And you treat her right. How about
that? Don't make her cater
to your whims. Right. Right.
Treat her right. Treat her like. See what she.
Speaker 1: Is. Isn't this, like, a weird thing
for a political event? A woman.
Speaker 4: A person of incredible
significance created in the image of God.
And you know what? You treat her right. And
then one day you do her the honor and show
her the respect of asking her to marry you.
Speaker 2: Now and then you go get married.
Speaker 1: Dating advice with Josh Hawley.
America Fest taking a very weird turn.
There were like incel vibes around the entire
thing. Then out came Dennis Prager and he said,
Sex is terrific. Okay, thanks, Dennis.
Speaker 2: The greatest need in life after
food and shelter is meaning it is even sex. And
sex is terrific. Just for the record. Right. And
there were good blacks and bad blacks.
Speaker 1: Did you guys know that there
are good blacks and bad blacks?
Speaker 2: There are good and
bad lesbians. There are good women and bad
women. There are good men and bad men. There
are good whites and bad whites. We don't give.
Unidentified: A damn about whether you're white.
We don't give a damn whether you're black.
Speaker 2: Just like you. Y you. You brush
away your bad breath and you shower away your bad
odor. You should brush away your bad mood. You owe
it to everyone in your life. Men can be lesbians.
Are you out of your minds? Yes, they are. We are
living in the age of chaos and the greatest.
Speaker 1: All right. So there's Dennis
Prager, a very, very messed up video. It's
it's just weird because so much of the stuff
they talk about is meaningless. Like it
helps no one achieve anything or solve
any problem. It's totally disconnected from
the real world. And then a guy named Benny
Johnson got a standing ovation for yelling
Fauci for prison. This is that this is the
level of what they have going on solving the real
problems of the world, as you can see. Oh, Dr..
Speaker 4: Fauci is resigning.
Unidentified:
This is what my boy had to say about Dr. Foushee.
Speaker 4: Just in time for Christmas.
Unidentified: And I'm just sick of seeing
him. I know. He says he's got to retire,
so I need to grab that little elf and chuck
him. Ladies and gentlemen, my pronouns are
cross if you fancy. Oh, gosh.
Speaker 1: Oh, my goodness. That's
America Fest. So if you were hoping to learn
what is their legislative agenda for these two
years that they will be controlling the House?
You didn't get it. If you were hoping to figure
out what is the moral framework within which they
believe government should. I can't even say it
seriously. Government should operate. You didn't
get that. You got fire. Fauci jailed. Fauci,
prosecute. Fauci. Fauci, retire. And you got my
pronouns are I one and my pronouns are prosecute
FAUCI. That's basically America Fest. That's
what we got. But these events bring people
together. They do them for a reason. They do them
for a reason. And the left should figure it out.